♪
both: OH, HELLO.
- OKAY, SO, GIL--
SO I LOOKED OVER
YOUR CHART--
- OF COURSE,
I'M GIL FAIZON.
- AND I'M GEORGE ST. GEEGLAND
HIS ASSOCIATE.
- SO I LOOKED OVER YOUR CHART,
AND YOU HAVE MERCURY POISONING.
- THANK YOU.
- NO, ACTUALLY, IT'S TERRIBLE.
YOU HAVE HIGH LEVELS
OF MERCURY IN YOUR BLOOD,
WHICH IS A VERY TOXIC POISON.
- AND THAT'S WHAT
FREDDIE MERCURY DIED OF?
- NO, HE DIED OF AIDS.
- RIGHT.
HE WAS POISONED BY IT.
SO IT WAS MERCURY'S
POISONING.
- NO, ACTUALL--
- WE'RE SAYING THE SAME THING.
- CAN I ASK YOU ABOUT
SOME OF YOUR SYMPTOMS?
ARE YOU FEELING FATIGUE?
- YEAH.
- MUSCLE WEAKNESS?
- OKAY, ANY PEELING SKIN?
- YEAH, IT PEELS RIGHT OFF.
- LIKE WALLPAPER.
- WELL, THESE ARE ALL SYMPTOMS
OF MERCURY POISONING, SO...
- I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW YOU COULD HAVE THIS.
YOU JUST GOT A CLEAN BILL
OF HEALTH.
- YEAH. I JUST WENT THROUGH
A DOCTORS CHECKUP.
- WHO WAS THE PHYSICIAN?
- ABOUT A MONTH AGO,
I SAW DR. WONG.
- LOU WONG. YEAH.
- IS THAT YOUR PRIMARY
PHYSICIAN?
- HE WAS THE PRIMARY SUSPECT
IN A BOTCHED C-SECTION.
- YEAH.
- SO HE DIDN'T DO
ANY BLOOD WORK
OR ANYTHING?
- LOU WONG?
- NO, NO, NO.
HE WAS WAVING A GUN AROUND
AND SCREAMING.
RACE RIOT THIS, RACE RIOT THAT.
- YEAH.
- I'M GONNA PRESCRIBE
A SUPPLEMENT FOR YOU
OF SELENIUM,
AND I WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT YOU STOP EATING
ALL FISH.
- I MEAN, I EAT A LITTLE BIT
OF TUNA FISH.
- OCCASIONALLY TUNA FISH.
- OCCASIONALLY.
- OKAY, OCCASIONALLY.
UM, WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
- I DON'T KNOW,
I DON'T HAVE MORE THAN
THREE DOLLOPS OF TUNA,
YOU KNOW, PER MEAL.
- TWO, THREE ICE CREAM
SCOOP'S WORTH?
- YEAH. I MEAN, ABOUT
A "HANDSFUL" IS ONE DOLLOP.
- YOU HAVE THREE MEALS
OF TUNA FISH PER DAY?
- YOU GOTTA EAT BREAKFAST,
LUNCH, AND DINNER, DON'T YOU?
- THREE SQUARES, OR ROUNDS,
IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT TUNA DOLLOPS.
- OKAY.
- I DON'T THINK WE'VE BEEN
EATING TOO MUCH TUNA.
- OKAY. I RECOMMEND
THAT YOU SHOULD REALLY
STOP EATING TUNA ALTOGETHER.
- I DON'T THINK
THAT'S TOO MUCH TUNA.
- WELL, IT--IT IS.
- I'VE BEEN EATING...
TOO MUCH TUNA.
[clears throat]
- UH-OH.
- OH, WHAT COULD THIS BE?
- WHAT IS THIS?
- WHAT'S THIS?
- WHAT IS THE MEANING
OF THIS?
- WHAT'S THAT?
- IT'S A VERY OLD SANDWICH.
- YOU'VE JUST BEEN PRANKED.
- YOU IDIOT.
YOU STUPID BITCH.
THERE'S A SANDWICH
ON YOUR DESK NOW.
TOO MUCH TUNA.
[orchestral wind up]
- RIGHT. WELL, BESIDES
IT BEING MERCURY POISONING,
IT'S ACTUALLY FOOD POISONING
BECAUSE
THAT MAYONNAISE SEEMS WARM.
- I MEAN,
THE MAYONNAISE IS CURDLED,
BUT HE'S BUILT UP
A TOLERANCE.
- WELL, IT DOESN'T SMELL GOOD.
- IT'S TURNING, ISN'T IT?
- YEAH. AND I HAVE--
- PLUS, I SWITCHED OFF THE A.C.
WHEN I CAME IN.